I understand what you're saying but you
yeah you're you're putting your hands on
the [ __ ] deck before the even game
started yeah I think maybe you guys are
right no we are right we're telling you
right now maybe there's nobody tell me
and I could not admit it because I don't
think you're right and so I'm here
saying that I actually you know I agree
I don't know if it's how I'm gonna
manage it's so that when I do hear her
fart which I do or I discover one of her
shits in the toilet rarely yeah but I
have I took a photo of it by the bye-bye
I took a photo of one of her shits and
it is unnatural because of the color I'm
gonna show you I'll show you right now
I'll show you the color of it and it's
very movie unnatural please show my [ __ ]
to everybody now I show it to everybody
[Applause]
look there is no [ __ ] I say color in
there okay I think this is just first
off your fibers were bonding well this
time thank you it's a good shape mhm and
it you can even see a little bit of like
your mucous sack at the end no that's
just my ulcerative colitis Jonah don't
say oh that's the lighting it's very tan
it's a very light skinned Filipino Ryan
it's clearly the lighting cuz the water
in the toilet looks yeah thank you it's
like a cold brew that didn't brew along
like a watered down cold water down
canons have faded yeah so so that's
close [ __ ]
now if I would have discovered that [ __ ]
day one or day for week one yeah
this shit's not dark enough for me yeah
right I would have justified it so you
can't show all your hands so stop doing
bar burping in people's faces even when
I don't
that like my first relationship that I
was in again he was so [ __ ] into me
he haunted me and I was like oh no one's
ever liked me before I guess I'll start
dating I was 19 my first boyfriend and
and then all of a sudden I think he just
realized that he liked the chase more
and then dudes are always like you know
we're good because you have this like
overly neutral very reasonable approach
or like in conversation that I think
that you forget how to purr yeah I'm
just like yeah you just serve very like
okay let's get to the point what are you
about like it's very oh yeah overly it's
too reasonable to the point where a dick
would go flaccid is that what cuz that
I'm so reasonable I'm like yeah you just
gotta give him a little bit of a like a
little bit of a how do you use I'm dead
serious
I don't know how to do that I mean
usually show your breasts within the
first two minutes and that kind of but
that just you everybody
I've never seen your breasts oh yeah I
know doing it a funny way I will say you
are exactly like Bobby in that way where
you guys are both exhibitions that's you
that's another thing is is that when I
the reason why you don't I think you're
like at times you don't think that I
like you would that be okay or that I
might and that you're annoying me
oh yeah I always think I'm annoying yeah
you always like annoying people right
but the reason why you annoy me is
because you're so much like me in that
way but you're a girl so it's weird yeah
so he likes to poo in public you like to
pee in public yeah yeah and I just want
people to look at like my tits are my
[ __ ] but not in a sexual way yeah
that'll be annoyed by me I like exactly
Bobby that's exactly like me you want
people to watch me like doing things but
then when they watch me doing certain
things that I didn't ask them to watch
I'm like what the [ __ ] are you looking
at yeah yeah rational yeah
[Music]